okay so the new album is out you're on
99 of the album all right
um is this what is because because the
last time we talked to you I think you
did a distro deal with that with the
company introduction yeah yeah are you
still with them yeah I put that out I
put it out through varric and it's just
like um being with varic it just allowed
me to drop music how and when I'm free
YouTube you know I mean if I was on a
major with my rap stuff then it would be
like you know it would take three months
to get one song out so now it's like I
got two albums out in three months and
you know I mean I'm just building my fan
base up and it's just like it's like he
came on we got 10 000 followers in a
month like literally getting more
engagement than some rappers I know you
know for sure some of his posts go off
more than mine it's like you know I mean
it's just like it's I see real people be
becoming like big hit fans like man this
this [__] is like my favorite rapper
right now it's just wild to see no it is
crazy because it's almost like damn like
right away he touches down and like I
feel the same way I'm like yo this
dude's putting out harder [__] than like
99 of these and I feel like you're
filling a void in fact there's like a
void for like the [__] you're doing like
I like authentic West Coast yeah yeah
for sure like somebody you like really
believe is on that you know I mean 100
nah for sure and even just like the
Beats like the flow like it's not you
know we I mean you know we are in LA
we've been listening to the same dudes
rapping the same way for
like the last five or six years
everybody's some sort of Draco Shoreline
clone you know what I'm just not doing
some like future Thug Type [__] right
man 100 man I don't know what you're
saying we're keeping it up man this is
authentically you know I mean exactly
what you looking at is what you got you
know I mean this is like we've been
plotting this out for even before the
you know grinding my whole life [__] we
was talking about doing music and we had
the music but it's just like now it's
like I'm my best he his best he you know
willing to work to stay out of the
[__] and that's like that's that's
one of the top things you know I mean
it's the bigger than just you know my
son popping I'm about to just get on
some songs and try to make some money
get famous whatever it's like this [__]
is really in our soul to do this [__]
like we've been talking about it being
locked in on it yeah would you say for
you like uh you're the most motivated
because I think before he obviously gets
to deal with the Interscope right hs87
is [__]
I mean such a talented roster a guy shot
Audio Push can't money uh everybody uh
okay I was just talking about Kate
Roosevelt a couple weeks ago like Jesus
dude let's do me now man K Roosevelt was
like literally bro like the first Khalid
like they didn't got an identical voice
like bro but it's just like Tom and his
everything bro that [__] is you can't
call it and you can't just predict like
when it's gonna crack off for you on
that level you just gotta I was gonna
say obviously there's a gift and a curse
for everything to happen with you do you
feel like everything mentality wise work
ethic wise like you're fully like ten
toes in on the rap [__] now big hit oh
yeah mentally yup yup I mean as far as
like my heart right now really wasn't
into it like that you know I'm saying it
was just like I felt like I was it like
I missed my chance you know what I'm
saying from way back then I was waiting
so long so eager and [__] and uh but my
you know I was like trying to I was one
foot in one foot out trying to get my
bread you know was the status is
matching up like right now but my chili
ain't there man like you know I want it
right now you know what I'm saying so
but yeah but yeah I was like [__] it if
it worked it worked it's cool I'm the
same old you know I'm starting to feel
it a little more now I'm getting more
enthused because you know I'm [__]
with him on this Duo [__] that's more
energy he giving me energy I'm giving
him energy you know I'm saying it's
starting to work it's it's working I
mean you know I'm saying like we just
scratching the surface that's the funny
part we ain't even we ain't even Full
Speed Ahead yet right we're in first
gear right